[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs tout de suite le
sommaire le festival trois rivières
sauvages revient dimanche au 25 octobre
pour une troisième édition un spectacle
féerique à faire découvrir aux familles
et pour romantique les fermes de gally
dans les yvelines fait la citrouille ou
du samedi 24 au samedi 31 octobre des
ateliers proposés pendant huit jours
venez dessiner découper ou posez votre
citrouille et puis enfin l'agenda
complet de vos sorties du week end
au programme un spectacle une exposition
et du cinéma le festival thouaré lumière
sauvage s'illumine de nouveau à partir
de dimanche 25 25 octobre et pendant
tout l'hiver plus de mille animaux
personnages et plantes s'illumine un
spectacle féerique à découvrir en
famille interview express avec
christelle bercheny la directrice
générale du zoo
[Musique]
c'est entre stival féerique de long
terme qui sont d'origine chinoise dans
la création puisque ce sont des
structures qui sont métalliques et qui
sont recouvertes de soi et peintes à la
main ensuite à l'intérieur on y place à
des lumières led qui sont avec 6 min
chaque nuit on a créé un parcours qui
fait un kilomètre 5 et qui raconte
différentes histoires au fur et à mesure
vous vous allez pouvoir entrer dans un
monde un petit peu onirique avec un
village de petit zoo peu timide au
ensuite vous allez passer dans quelque
chose de plus naturel avec des ferries a
commandé des des arbres un petit peu
sorti de l'imagination et c'était
extrêmement important pour deux choses 1
effectivement ça fait partie aujourd'hui
de notre activité et les clients nous le
demande
et puis évidemment c'était parti
d'actifs du zoo et ça permet aussi aux
héros de rester ouvertes toute l'année
aujourd'hui
chose qui n'était pas possible avant
puisque l'activité pur zozos et
animalière l'hiver est très tellement de
météo des pentes que ben on équilibre et
pas forcément les hivers alors tant les
personnages c'est d'abord un moment de
décontraction et un moment oui à tout ce
qui va se passer un moment où on respire
et on passe de bons moments et on se
retrouve vraiment tous ensemble autour
dans un milieu naturel et dans un milieu
tchèque et les citrouilles peuvent-elles
aussi salut mais quand la nuit tombe
la fête de la citrouille revient aux
fermes de gally
l'événement a lieu sur les trois sites
dont deux se trouvent dans les yvelines
à saint cyr l'école et à sartrouville
des activités qui se déroulent pendant
huit jours
et pour en parler sur ce plateau justin
brasier bons soins soit alors en quoi
consiste cette fête
et bien c'est un atelier tout simplement
de fabrication de citrouille
c'est une tradition aux fermes de gally
et depuis plus de 20 ans c'est un
atelier qui concerne plutôt les enfants
en tout cas un public familial
elle permet de passer du beau des bons
moments à un conduit
les deux partagent surtout en ce moment
j'imagine qu'il faut beaucoup de
citrouilles pour réaliser ces ateliers
doudou ça provient finalement celle ci
trop bien ce sont des citrouilles
locales elles proviennent d'une
production cultivés à quelques centaines
de mètres de la ferme et s'y trouvent
ont posé pour ces ateliers de creusement
de citrouilles sont toutes des
citrouilles qui sont cultivés dans nos
champs dans la plaine de versailles là
on a cultivé depuis le début mai ap ap
après les saints de glace nos citrouille
et on les a récolté ces dernières
semaines un don qu'elle sortait juste à
côté on a cultivé 4 hectares qui
représente plusieurs milliers de
citrouille
elles sont présentées dans de grandes
caisses en bois un des palox les
visiteurs peuvent ensuite choisir eux
mêmes leurs citrouilles
selon la taille et la forme qu'ils
souhaitent c'est votre caisse en bois
vous avez plein de citrouille vous en
avez dès tout petit comme celles ci ont
été beaucoup plus grosse de forme plus
ou moins à pratiquer comme celles qui
sont derrière moi ou tout rond donc les
enfants vont choisir vraiment la
citrouille qu'il en fait plaisir qui les
inspirent ils vont dessiner avec un
marqueur avec un feutre les endroits où
je leur fais relais des sculptures le
découpe les animateurs réalise la
découpe pour des questions de sécurité
ils peuvent creuser leurs titres
eux-mêmes oui oui les enfants un
creusent leur citrouille et installe
même une bougie à l'intérieur pour
donner vie à leur création
et bien sûr ils repartent avec alors
chaque année certains fondent et
peut-être rigolote d'autres effrayante
même souriante vraiment le but c'est de
laisser libre cours à son imagination et
vous savez d'ailleurs que vous avez déjà
un creuset une citrouille bon j'avais
mais j'aimerais bien le faire un jour
c'était l'occasion cet atelier lui et
concernant d'ailleurs les gestes
barrière comment ils font du coup alors
il faut savoir qu'ils se font très
attention respect des mesures en
sanitaires en vigueur
une partie des ateliers et réalisé en
extérieur il propose même de venir avec
sa propre cuillère ou son propre fait
même si bien sûr il y à du matériel
désinfecter à disposition où se
concentrait sur l'atelier de claude
baude citrouilles en multipliant les
pôles de creusement
en ayant plus d'animateurs de telle
sorte qu'on accueille des groupes plus
restreints et en étant une famille
portable est alors combien de temps dure
l'atelier alors l'atelier est dure 30
minutes après bien sûr ils peuvent se
promener dans la ferme aller voir les
animaux partir à la découverte des bois
et je veux aussi accès au labyrinthe
les responsables de la ferme par contre
demande simplement aux visiteurs de
limiter leur temps sur le site à 2
heures tout simplement pour éviter
d'accueillir trop de monde
merci justin pour toutes les
informations et d'ailleurs on va
justement rester dans le thème
d'halloween
vous êtes plutôt sorcier ou scientifique
fou justin on va durer sorcier et bien à
la bergerie nationale de rambouillet
vous pouvez être les deux durant les
vacances scolaires c'est pas que sorcier
1 revient pour une nouvelle édition
au programme de nombreuses animations un
reportage de michael et demi d'euros
le lait de volts igol va permettre à ce
petit garçon de voler comme un aigle
dans la maison à verdelais d'autres
sortes de l'est aux pouvoirs
extraordinaires sont présents j'ai
préparé un petit peu d'émotion
particulière avec le lait nos vaches du
lait entier pasteurisé forcément j'ai
rajouté un petit peu de pouvoirs
magiques dedans pour donner de la
couleur et pouvoir avoir des effets
différents on peut devenir rond comme un
ballon on peut grandir comme une vache
en l'espace de 15 secondes jusqu'au 1er
novembre de 14h à 18h des animations
autour du thème d'harry potter sont
proposés le but est de découvrir quatre
maisons la basse cour avec des oiseaux
et leurs oeufs
les différentes qualités de la laine
chez les moutons la traction animale
chez les chevaux et les composants du
lait chez les vaches le côté magique et
le côté scientifique les expériences les
expérimentations le côté ludique sont
des choses qui sont très appréciés au
niveau des enfants justement les enfants
de mme et participe à de nombreuses
épreuves diverses et variées devaient
remplir un carnet magique tout au long
de leur aventure
il y avait une épreuve où valait
trombone potion j'ai choisi
[Musique]
une pochette de force ensuite dernière
étape de cet après-midi anti aux coloris
avec la peinture à base de comme les
activités sont diversifiées
ils n'ont pas le temps de s'ennuyer et
factures ont beaucoup en fin de journée
un match de quidditch est aussi
organisée l'idée de ces animations
halloween est de faire découvrir en
famille la ferme et ses animaux
la soirée lampions frissons et
dégustation prévue mercredi 21 octobre
et quand elle annulé à cause du
couvre-feu et si l'imaginaire
d'halloween ne vous fait peur d'autres
activités sont prévues dans les yvelines
ce week end comme à poissy ou un
spectacle de magie sera proposée au
musée du jouet dimanche 25 octobre à
14h30 et mercredi 28 octobre à la même
heure ce spectacle sera animé par jérôme
sol ou de lagence des magiciens
réservation obligatoire
plongez dans l'univers miniatures des
playmobil au château de breteuil à
choisel une nouvelle exposition sur le
thème des films cultes est présenté ce
week end samedi et dimanche de 10 heures
à 18 heures et pour les plus petits des
histoires au hasard sont racontées par
sophie destanque samedi 24 octobre de
10h30 à 11h à la médiathèque 17 mar à
elancourt
[Musique]
sauvé est rénové des avions ou des
morceaux d'avion c'est le but de
l'association saint cyr aviation partage
qui dévoile ses trouvailles au grand
public tout près de l'aérodrome de saint
cyr l'école son président se démène pour
faire vivre ce petit musée atypique un
montage de lucas houdart c'est le petit
dernier de la collection ce noratlas
arrivé il ya deux semaines est un avion
à double creux qui s'ouvre à l'arrière
pour pouvoir charger de la marchandise
ou sauter en parachute
son premier vol date de 1959 il a eu de
carrière elle a une carrière militaire
où ils transportaient donc ce que je
vous ai dit de matériel militaire et des
parachutistes ou des toubous des troupes
et ensuite il a été vendu à une société
qui s'appelle transvaal rc le noratlas
numéro 180 et qui travaillait qui
voulaient travailler pour la sernam et
il ya eu des problèmes avec avec la
ferme est en fait cet avion n'a pas eu
le temps de travailler
pierre farman le président de
l'association est le petit-fils de dick
norman pionniers de l'aviation qui a
oeuvré à la naissance d'air france c'est
grâce à sa famille connue dans le monde
aéronautique que de nombreuses personnes
lui donne des pièces au lieu de les
jeter
cette parcelle à deux pas des pistes de
l'aérodrome devient une sorte de musée à
ciel ouvert qui a quand même une
particularité on n'aura pas jamais le
droit d'y rentrer c'est ce sont des
avions des montées donc contendant s'il
fallait sécuriser on aurait pu la place
de mettre autre chose donc on est
extrêmement près de la clôture et on
regarde à travers la clôture et on peut
donc y voir deux avions le nord atlas et
un falcon 900 mais aussi un tas de
pièces détachées comme un morceau de
falcon 50 et une entrée d'air de boeing
il ya des volets d'evel 2
des morceaux de turbines de l'autre côté
un train d'atterrissage quoi il ya un
petit peu de tout l'idée est vraiment de
faire sortir de son contexte les les
pièces d'avion pour montrer comment
commencer fabriquer la prochaine
acquisition de l'association sera
certainement un moteur de mirage et
d'autres pièces devraient arriver
également en novembre ainsi que des
panneaux d'affichage sur la clôture pour
donner des détails sur ces objets que
faut-il à aller voir au cinéma cette
semaine la parole est donnée aujourd'hui
à vincent mirabel professeur de cinéma à
versailles et membre du jury s'y
glissent au festival san sebastian il
nous parle du film trunk on les écoute
[Musique]
drunk qui signifie ivre est un film qui
peut vous enivrer d'abord vous allez
quitter le confinement est partie au
danemark
là vous allez rencontrer quatre amis
tous professeurs dans le secondaire et
chacun va tester la théorie selon
laquelle on améliore sa vie avec 0,5
gramme d'alcool de plus dans le sens
drunk est une comédie avec un formidable
vote et dans un cours d'histoire
et puis le ton change et on se ressaisit
à la fin sur le plan esthétique c'est
très soignée s'est posée et puis sur le
plan du message c'est évidemment que
l'on se détournent des faux remède pour
s'ouvrir à la vraie vie au final on
termine par une danse de joie
magnifiquement interprété par matt
miquel celle qui a reçu au festival de
san sebastian le prix d'interprétation
avec ses trois autres collègues
ce film a été sélectionné à cannes il
n'a pas pu être projetées là bas c'est
le moment de se rattraper
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de ce cette ut loisirs
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
la semaine prochaine pour de nouvelles
idées sorties bonne soirée à jeudi
prochain
[Musique]